so you guys probably heard already a
couple weeks ago Sam Harris and Ben
Affleck were on Real Time with Bill
Maher and they got into a debate about
Islamophobia and Ben Affleck basically
called Bill Maher and Sam Harris racist
I did a video breakdown of it which will
annotate - right here uh but now
Berkeley University uh has put up a
petition on change.org where they don't
want Bill Maher to be their commencement
speaker so we've got them text from
there
Bill Maher is a plain bigoted and racist
who has no respect for the values UC
Berkeley students stand for in a time
where climate is a priority for all on
campus we cannot invite an individual
who himself perpetuates a dangerous
learning environment Bill Maher's public
statements on various religions and
cultures are offensive and his dangerous
rhetoric has found its way into our
campus communities so again I did a
video about this and I hope you guys
will click in and take a look now Bill
Maher out of you've seen his documentary
Religulous he hates all related he has
been very clear he hatred he is stood
for every liberal principle is a guy who
has a thirty year career uh standing for
pretty much everything uh liberal uh and
until Ben Affleck basically called me
racism no one racist no one thought Bill
Maher was a racist um so I think this is
a little disingenuous by UC Berkeley I
have a couple other thoughts on that but
I'm gonna let you guys chime in first is
it's just bad for free speech uh just
removing Bill Maher for a second that
this is happening all over the place we
keep hearing about this where there
commencement speeches from different
people condi rice all over the political
map where suddenly the students don't
want to hear from anyone that they
disagree with it is bad for free speech
I mean you suck it up but also look it's
Berkeley I'm not surprised on what sort
of petition yeah I mean III was like the
icon in a way I I actually would I I i
if I were a professor I'd be like yeah
petition you know this is exercise your
right to be heard in whatever but on the
flip side you know and and I I was
raised religious and I am no longer
supporter of Christianity however I will
have to say look it uh I think Bill
Maher has a point when it comes to the
music you're gonna tack is like of all
the things that I've said in
you're going to come to come come at me
with this one thing with religion right
is attacked all yeah the big three the
whole movie was about the big three this
one is specifically about Islam - and
I'm just saying well you know the people
have a disagreed with real you know uh
speakers with religious backgrounds or
speakers of other other areas it seems a
little hypocritical you're gonna go
after him for this one thing and I feel
like any commencement speaker you get
for any college you're gonna find
something that you can disagree with
you're gonna find something that all the
entire student body doesn't a hundred
percent agree with something right so I
know a lot of people would argue that
Bill Maher has been the gold standard
for liberal values he has always fought
for liberal values he in his also stood
for progressive values he wants our
troops out he always talks about we have
thirty thousand troops in Germany what
the hell are they doing there he wants
our government to be smaller he wants
our politicians to be more accountable
all the things that liberals always talk
about women's rights gay rights etc etc
now I get it he got into some hot water
here I but I only see this as bad I
think where the frustrations come from
because of that line at least his
history of being such a Lib yeah this
big fat Lebanese always stand for the
right things and honestly I don't think
he's always believed it you think he's
playing a role and I think is that this
is this thing has been bigger I wonder
tater playing a role family yeah he's
like let me let me like fit my weight he
might months they take this role come in
and do what I can because this is a
money maker yeah and it has been it's
been great for him but I don't think
it's been a secret to this guy has some
I guess unfounded feelings and thoughts
about people I mean the latest thing is
that just came out I mean he cited
chiming about Mike Brown and Ferguson
that guy was acting like a thug he
wasn't such a nice chill guy he saw a
lot like who's who's the the old talk
show with the clear eyes commercials and
the guy that the the boring Oh God
clearance give me something clear as a
committee bin Stein yeah Ben Stein went
came out and said oh yeah you know
Michael Brown was acting like a scary
big scary guy that he is cuz he's just
his size and his blackness
yeah talk about scary he was Bill
Maher's said very similar things it's
like this week yeah so I mean he's not
it's not a surprise and people have
known this for a while certain
committees made
they know more than others but it
doesn't catch the attention this caught
the attention and now it's happening to
a more and by the way I think it's good
that people held accountable things they
said it never happened before cos we
have this internet thing where
everything you said gets taken down and
memorized and reposted and every one
reason goes damn I would never know he
said that less you told me that yeah so
in a in a liberal Bastion like Berkeley
you can't be too surprised can happen if
if JQ goes to try speaking Liberty
University they're gonna go there's got
a out here everywhere not okay so
even if all right so if let's say I'll
grant what you're saying that he said
some things that yet I mean he's a
comedian and comedians are supposed to
put limits used to host a show called
politically incorrect the guys trying to
be politically incorrect right um but
what does this say about the
universities that just college itself
college is supposed to be the most
open-minded place you're supposed to
learn all the stuff that you take into
the real world guess what there are real
bigots in the real world there are real
racists in the real world so if you
don't allow these people to speak and
that's why I brought up the condi rice
thing because it's happening on both
sides condi rice on the right there's
University you're saying we don't hear
from her and and Bill Maher's on letters
and we don't hear from him it's like
guess what you guys when you get your
jobs a week later with you know when you
graduate you have a job a week later
you're experts for work if you
think Bill Maher is a bigot wait till
you get to the real world's what what
can we do to make college more tolerant
it doesn't strike it's tolerant if the
colleges remove them as speakers then we
have a problem
like I said everyone's allowed to
express their opinion but I've been
removing speaker it is actually it so
what's gonna happen right this but condi
rice got the boot from that one uh
there's there's been plenty of other
examples of these he's a conservative
commentator he's been taken away from
two of them um another one this only
looks exactly like Ben Stein we're like
generally I have too big of a black
people you're gonna be worse ABC does
the Sunday morning shows but he got
booted from two commencements he's right
so what is it about the college cuz when
I was in college maybe it was the amount
of weed that I smoked I was pretty
tolerant and it has transcended itself
into my adult life but what is it about
college now that why don't they think
because I would guess is that these
Berkeley kids probably agree and this is
I think what you're saying before I
would guess that they agree 95% with
Bill Maher so if they don't agree you
don't have to I don't agree with myself
a hundred percent
so they're picking 5% and saying I don't
even want to hear from him and so why
are why are they so intolerant where
what happened a free speech intolerance
I mean and I think it's one point out
when this was brought up I believe one
of the articles I read they said there's
free speech everyone gets to have it we
don't not believe he gets disabled he
wants but we shouldn't give him a
megaphone to say it I mean there's the
guys who stand outside of football games
and hold of John 3:16 Zanden yell
through megaphone they can do it but if
someone says hey hey guy come here let
me have you speak to but the hope the
whole group of graduating students who
go yet he gets to say it but don't put
in front of me and give him a voice to
spew whatever it is he's gonna say yeah
I understand it and it could get out of
control I don't think it's out of
control yet yeah okay my my last thought
on this uh is I grew up in a world where
comedians were supposed to be edgy
they're supposed to find the line and
they're supposed to cross it I I have
this fear that the left is starting to
eat its own you know you mean yes if you
agree with Bill Maher 95% but then you
don't want to hear him because a 5%
would guess what one day they're gonna
turn on you too you know to me like this
is harmful I think is the problem that's
that could just harm regime does harm
but but isn't that the point of free
speech we're all gonna see yeah
there's no answer there's no answer I
suppose anyway we'll see what happens
they have not officially decided to go
with this yet or not